hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new and aspiring software engineers
and today we're doing a little unboxing
so
as i revealed i work for dreamworks
animations and so they sent me a couple
of packages expecting some to be
functional like computers and whatnot
but i think i get some swag also which
would be nice because
i like free things so
so yeah i just wanted to give you all an
inside look of if you are about to start
your first career or your first job in
the tech field what you may be able to
expect of your new job what can be sent
to you and so yeah i
i have three i keep looking over here
because i have three
boxes one's like
this big and i couldn't take i can't
take this off i still
yeah please ignore this i just got back
from lollapalooza in chicago
and
i still don't have like
knives or
anything or scissors or anything in this
apartment and so i haven't been able to
take this off yet because i moved in and
then two days later went to chicago so
literally i have nothing to do more
shopping today so you won't see it in
you know future videos god forbid a year
from now you're still seeing this in
videos but i have a small
box kind of like that then i have like a
box like twice that size and i have a
pretty huge
box over here and so we'll just go
smallest to largest so
let's see here so this is the first box
i haven't opened anything
uh
i'm using my keys to open because again
i don't have anything in this apartment
i don't have a knife i don't have a
letter opener
[Music]
oh interesting
it's a
track pad i don't know let me try to
focus in on this
yeah it's a
track pad
not gonna lie to you i have never
used one
before
magic trackpad two i don't know what
generation i don't know if that's the
most recent generation or if that's like
one or two behind
but i think it'll do the job i've never
used one i imagine it'll be a
nice thing to use especially with bigger
screens and everything but okay
okay okay so now the
second
box
which is yeah
bigger than that let's see
oh wow
it's a whole
magic keyboard i believe all the
tech and materials i'll be getting are
from apple but yeah it's the magic
keyboard again i imagine
it is
the latest one like 2021 2020
2. um
i cannot tell but that's what i imagine
so i'll open that
soon as well and now we have
a humongous
i can't even
i can't even stand it up
it's huge
so i
i'm now i'm wondering if it's going to
be a desktop
like a hole
or a laptop
because i was expecting a laptop like a
macbook
oh
it is
a
backpack it is a backpack full oh wow
it's a backpack full of like everything
else so yeah it says this is the
backpack oh and there's my picture
oh that's cool
oh that's cute that's cute but yeah it
says comcast on it because dreamworks i
don't know who knows those dreamworks is
under the umbrella of nbcuniversal who
is under the umbrella of comcast so yes
dreamworks is under the umbrella of
comcast and so
there's the backpack
but this tough image
oh wow
this is huge
so
i have the macbook pro in here
um the 16 inch it's the 16 inch
it's a 60 inch macbook pro
in space gray 16 gigabyte
okay i like this it's heavy like wow
it is heavy so i'm going to open that
soon
but i also
have an iphone
and
this is the iphone 11 in black
128 gigabytes
i think the phone i'm using like the
phone i have is a 10
x like a 10x s so yeah this is the next
generation of i don't know what
generation iphone is on right now but
yeah this is
cool like it's in black my favorite
color actually not really my favorite
color is more of a powder pink
even though i don't really show it
um we have
a multimedia hub
from belkin let me make sure you can see
it
but no this looks great because it looks
like you can connect a whole lot
in here so that'll be perfect
then we
have using my keys
so i have a set of air pods then i have
an otterbox phone case
which is really nice because i be
dropping then
what is this oh
i thought this was um like a portable
charger it's just a charger so perfect
so we have another charger from wall
port and
that is it for this box there's some
more in here though
we're almost done though we have a shirt
so it says comcast nbc universal
core tech
so that's really very exciting
i like the color i like the color a ton
we have
that's funny
some coffee and tea
i think it goes like this is what would
be in their office and
i'm primarily from what i believe going
to be working from home
so i think they're like here girl
we got you
um we have a ticket
i don't know where to
um
like comcast also owns universal studios
so i know we get tickets free tickets to
that but i don't
imagine that this is the ticket to enter
i may be wrong i may be wrong but i
don't imagine i think this is more of a
cute momento or maybe
redeemable for like for the office or
something and we have a folder
this is it
let me really look before i get in
trouble for not
taking everything yeah looks like we're
good enough do we have a folder oh i
don't think anything isn't oh
okay so it has a little welcome
letter
in the folder we're excited for you to
kick off
let's talk about orientation so by the
time you watch this video orientation
would have been the previous week for me
but as i'm sitting here right now
orientation is tomorrow starts tomorrow
for the entire week so they're just
talking about the agenda
and powering my laptop and all that
so i will read it in full detail when i
am not looking at a camera
as much as i love y'all i can't read
under pressure like that y'all um
oh
oh wait
we also got some snacks
we also got some snacks yes i think
they're trying to just have like a
little like things that would be in the
office for me you know
but it's like oh it's not she's on the
office so let's just
ship it to her so that's so nice
oh is there more
but yeah
but i'm really happy with all this i'm
excited to set all of this up and do a
little desk
setup for y'all i hope this shed some
light onto what you can expect to
receive from your welcome package if you
just charge working at a place as a new
hire new developer or even you know mid
senior level i imagine you'll still get
this stuff you know um so now i hope you
all enjoyed this just a more chill
relaxed video but let me know what
questions you have below follow me on
instagram at the black female engineer i
answer a lot of questions through there
and i like to update you all on things
through there but thank you so much for
watching i'll talk to you later bye